PROFESSOR: This was a
differential equation
for the energy eigenstates phi.
Supposed to be
normalizable functions.
We looked at this equation
and decided we would first
clean out the constant.
We did that by replacing x
by a unit-free coordinate u.
For that we needed a constant
that carries units of length,
and that constant is
given by this combination
of the constants of the problem.
H-bar, m, and omega--
the frequency of the oscillator.
We also defined the
unit-free energy--
calligraphic e.
In terms of which
the real energies
are given by multiples
of h omega over 2.
So the problem has now become--
and this whole
differential equation
turns into this simple
differential equation.
Simple looking--
let's say properly--
differential equation for phi--
as a function of u--
which is the new
rescaled coordinate,
and where the energy
shows up here.
And for some reason,
this equation
doesn't have
normalizable solutions.
Unless those
energies are peculiar
values that allow a
normalizable solution to exist.
We looked at this equation
for u going to infinity,
and realized that e to the
plus minus u squared over 2
are the possible dependencies.
So we said-- without
loss of generality--
that phi could be written
as some function of u
to be determined times
this exponential.
And we hope for a function
that may be a polynomial.
So that the dependence
at the infinity
is governed by this factor.
So with this for
the function phi,
we substitute back into
the differential equation.
Now the unknown is h.
So you can take the derivatives
and find this differential
equation for h-- a second
order differential equation.
And that's the equation.
It may look a little
more complicated
than the equation
we started with,
but it's much simpler, actually.
There would be no polynomial
solution of this equation,
but there may be a
polynomial solution
of the second equation.
So we have to solve
this equation now.
And the way to do it is to
attempt a serious expansion.
So we would try to write h
of u equals the sum over j.
Equals 0 to infinity.
Ak, u to the k.
P equals 0 to infinity.
Now, one way to
proceed with this
is to plot this expansion into
the differential equation.
You will get three sums.
You will have to shift indices.
It's kind of a
little complicated.
Actually, there's a simpler
way to do this in which you
think in the following way.
You have this series
and you imagine
there's a term aj, u to the j,
plus aj plus 1, u to the j plus
1, plus aj plus 2.
U to the j plus 2.
And you say, let me
look at the terms with u
to the j in the
differential equation.
So just look at the terms
that have a u to the power j.
So from this second--
h vu squared-- what do we get?
Well, to get a term that has
a u to the j, you must start--
if you take two derivatives
and to end up with u to the j--
you must have started with this.
U to the j plus 2.
So this gives you j
plus 2, j plus 1--
taking the two derivatives--
aj plus 2, u to the j.
From the series, the term with
u to the j from the second hvu
squared is this one.
How about for minus 2u dh, du?
Well, if I start with h and
differentiate and then multiply
by u, I'm going to get u to
the j starting from u to the j.
Because when I differentiate
I'll get u to the j minus 1,
but the u will bring it back.
So this time I get minus 2 a j--
or minus 2.
One derivative j.
That's aj, u to the j.
So it's from this
[? step. ?] Minus 2.
You differentiate
and you get that.
From the last term,
e minus 1 times h,
it's clearly e minus
1 times aj u to the j.
So these are my three terms that
we get from the differential
equation.
So at the end of the
day, what have we gotten?
We've gotten j plus 2, j plus
1, aj plus 2, minus 2jaj,
plus e minus 1 aj.
All multiplied by u to the j.
And that's what we
get for u to the j.
So if you wish, for the
whole differential equation--
all of the
differential equation--
you get the sum from j equals
0 to infinity of these things.
And that should
be equal to zero.
So this is the
whole left-hand side
of the differential equation.
We calculated what is
the term u to the j.
And there will be terms
from u to the zeroth
to u to the infinity.
So that's the whole thing.
And we need this differential
equation to be solved.
So this must be zero.
And whenever you have a function
of u like a polynomial-- well,
we don't know if it's a
polynomial-- and it stops.
But if you have a
function of u like this,
each coefficient must be 0.
Therefore, we have
that j plus 2,
times j plus 1, times aj plus
2, is equal to 2 j plus 1 minus
e, aj.
I set this whole combination
inside brackets to 0.
So this term is equal to
this term and that term
on the other side.
You get a plus 2j.
A plus 1 and minus e.
So basically this is
a recursion relation.
Aj plus 2 is equal
to 2j plus 1 minus e,
over j plus 2, j
plus 1 times aj.
And this is perfectly nice.
This is what should
have happened
for this kind of
differential equation--
a second-order linear
differential equation.
We get a recursion
that jumps one step.
That's very nice.
And this should hold
for j equals 0, 1, 2--
all numbers.
So when you start solving this,
there's two ways to solve it.
You can decide, OK, let me
assume that you know a0--
you give it.
Give a0.
Well, from this equation--
from a0-- you can calculate a2.
And then from a2 you
can calculate a4.
And successively.
So you get a2, a4--
all of those.
And this corresponds to an even
solution of the differential
equation for h.
Even coefficients.
Even solution for h.
Or-- given this recursion--
you could also give a1--
give it-- and then
calculate a3, a5--
and those would be
an odd solution.
So you need two
conditions to solve this.
And those conditions
are a0 and a1,
which is the same as specifying
the value of the function h
at 0--
because the value of the
function h at 0 is a0.
And the value of the derivative
of the function at 0,
which is a1.
[INAUDIBLE] h of mu is a0
plus a1u plus a2u squared.
So the derivative
at 0 is [? h1. ?]
And that's what you must have
for solving a differential
equation-- a second-order
differential equation for h.
You need to know the value
of the function at zero
and the value of the
function at the derivative
of the function--
at zero, as well.
And then you can
start integrating it.
So this first gives you a
solution a0 plus a2u squared,
plus a4u to the fourth.
And the second is an a1u plus
a3u cubed, plus these ones.
So all looks pretty much OK.